it's alessandra okay so
what is the uh yeah so our main problem
for this talk is the following so it's
it's a problem about bivariate forms
or univariate polynomials
uh
so you might think that there are no
open problems left for univariate
polynomials
uh but in fact that's not the case
um
so
so given uh
so yeah so it's called
wearing problem
or symmetric tensor decomposition
but in this talk we're just going to
focus mostly on bivariate things
although
many things that i will say are going to
be general so
and i will try to point that out
so the problem i give you a form
uh
in two variables
of degree d
and i want to write f
as
a sum
or linear combination
of powers
of linear forms in a minimal way so i
want to write this in a minimal way so
minimum with respect to r
smallest r
and these allies are linear forms
and the r the minimal r is referred to
as wearing rank
or symmetric tensor rank
okay
so
let me give you another
completely equivalent problem
uh maybe a little bit more a little bit
more specific or a little bit more
hands-on this this one might feel a
little bit uh
well if you haven't thought about it a
little bit strange so equivalent problem
so this eq this is equivalent when
degree is even
so when degree is even i can
equivalently ask the following given
even a henkel matrix
h so what is a henkel matrix so h looks
like this
and
guess let me fix sizes k plus 1 by k
plus 1
this k refers to the 2d so
so the ankle matrix looks like this it
is
constant on anti-diagonals cd minus 1 cd
minus 1 cd minus 2
cd minus 2 cd minus 2
and then we go all the way down
see zero
so equivalent problem is so i'm giving
you a henkel matrix
now of course if i want to write it as a
sum of rank one matrices
how many matrices do i need
i want to write a given matrix as a sum
of rank 1 matrices
how many matrices would i need normally
yeah i should just need rank h
uh arrange rank h matrices but now what
i want to do is i want to write it as a
sum of rank 1 ankle matrices
right that might be more difficult
because you know
because well now i'm reinforcing that
rank once sorry that the rank once also
have the same constructor so now right h
write h as a sum
of rank
ankle
matrices so of course i'm always going
to need at least rank h but sometimes i
might need more because not all of my
rank ones might be hinkle in my minimal
decomposition that you know i get from
usual matrices
okay does that make sense so in fact i
claim that if i take
the following matrix 0 1 1 0 and then
the rest is just 0. this is clearly
henkel this is rank 2
but if i want to write it in this way
i'm going to need
i'm going to need the
rank one matrices d rank one ankles
we will actually see later in the talk
why this is true
and we will also see later in the talk
why these two problems are equivalent
but i wanted to give you this one well
it's completely equivalent to that one
also
i don't know i think there's probably a
lot more papers written about hinkle
matrices
than about uh
bivariate symmetric tensor decomposition
or bivariate wiring problem
uh but over r so basically again so what
this question we can ask so i
specifically put k x y but k can be r or
c
i mean for us
these are the two fields of interest for
this talk
and
over c
everything about this problem or
equivalently this problem was already
understood very well by sylvester
so it dates to 1850s maybe 60s something
like that
but over real numbers are still quite a
few things that are not very well
understood
okay
so
are there questions
are you okay do you understand what i'm
going to spend you know you're going to
spend like the next 55 minutes in the
stock
uh do you understand what i'm going to
talk about
that's okay
yes
okay
so let's move on so the main uh
what is the main tool here and this is
also
basically uh
well in bivariate uh
in bivariate cases also due to sylvester
but maybe not in non-bivariant case
more recent so it's called a polarity
llama so i need to introduce a few
things so here the discussion is going
to be general for a while it's not
really bivariate
so okay so i need to define a polar
ideal
okay so now given a polynomial g
uh
doesn't matter in how many variables if
i write g as the sum of c alpha x to the
alpha this is multinomial notation i can
associate to it
a differential operator which just does
exactly what g does
except uh
with differentiation
so basically if i see x1 squared then i
replace it with differentiating by x1
twice
and okay so
now i define a polar ideal of f
as
the set of all g's
such that differential operator of g
kills f
okay so maybe
maybe an example
example
so if i look at x y to the d minus one
it's easy it's easier when i pick a
monomial right you couldn't think you
know what
uh what differential operators are going
to kill this well so certainly
x squared when i took a differential
operator of x squared that's going to
kill this guy because i differentiate
with respect to x twice the differential
operator of y to the d is going to kill
this guy i'm differentiating with
respect to y too many times and in fact
uh i guess i should write perp so the a
polar ideal is generated exactly by
these two guys
x squared y to the d
and uh
and in two variables these a polar
ideals are very well understood so fact
maybe i'm not sure who this is due to
maybe uh probably it's already known by
sylvester but
uh
fact exercise so
when f is bivariate so this is very
special to bivariate i will sorry
i will say a few things so what happens
uh for
more variables but
anyway so when f is bivariate then f
perp is always generally it's always
like this so it's generated by two guys
maybe this is too low
um is it too low
it's okay so well okay yeah but then um
i'm also going to move even lower so
let's avoid that at least
so f prop is always generated by two
guys
and in fact we know even quite a bit
more
uh we know the degree well kind of know
the degrees
we know the sum of their degrees
the degree of g1
plus degree of g2
is d plus two
and g one and g two
uh let me say it in words have no zeros
no common zeros over c
or in more advanced slightly more
advanced language they're a complete
intersection
okay so this is what's known about
bivariate polar ideals so if you take
more variables then
in three variables there is the uh
boost bound eisenbach structure theorem
that essentially describes all i do all
a polar ideals
in three variables so it's beautiful but
a bit more complicated and if you go to
four or more variables then
i think it's fair to say that it's
very much wide open despite there being
many many sort of partial results there
is nothing that comes close to touching
any sort of classification uh even even
for small examples so even if you fix
i don't know your degree to be not too
large so you don't ask for anything in
four variables but i don't know but you
fix some
not too small and not too large degree
we still don't really know
what's going on
okay but
luckily for us
today we're talking about bivariate
things
so uh here we understand everything
so
okay so now what use
what use is this a polar ideal well
the use of the polar ideal comes from
yeah a polarity llama so i'm going to
state it for bivariate
uh for bivariate forms and it's going to
be an exercise
to generalize the statement and maybe
even prove it
for higher number of variables
okay
so a polarity limit so we have f is a
bivariate polynomial
and now
i can write f as a linear combination
of sums of powers so now every li i can
write
it's a linear form a i x plus b i y
so f can be written in this way
if and only if
the following polynomial so i form a
polynomial g
which is
b 1 x minus a 1 y
b 2 x
minus a 2 y
up to
however many
vrx
minus ary
so this guy so g
is in the a polar ideal of f
so the differential operator of g
kills f
okay
so
what's going on here especially you look
at this why are a's and the b switched
why are why is there a minus instead of
plus what is the meaning of this
polynomial
right what is the meaning of this
polynomial so that we can generalize it
to
higher uh number of variables so the
idea is the following so
notice that okay so these allies you
know i can think of them as being dual
to points
a i b i in p1 if you want
i should really make them projective
and
how is this polynomial built this
polynomial is a polynomial that vanishes
at all of these points
and in fact this is special for
bivariate it is
the generator
of the uh
principle ideal of everything that
vanishes at these points
okay so in fact this g just generates
the ideal
of uh all polynomial by various
polynomials that vanish at the points
corresponding to the decomposition
okay so hopefully
this can point you toward the correct
generalization
in more than two variables
questions
okay so now let me sort of say this
again well not say it again but what is
a polarity lemma let me sort of
say it in words
what is the bottom line what is a
polarity lemma saying about the rank of
f
it is saying the following so the a
polarity lemma says that
this is
kind of a better well i prefer to think
of it this way so
so it says the following
rank f
or this is an implication is equal to r
if and only if a polar ideal of f
contains
a form
g
of degree r
such that g has distinct roots
and factors completely
well if it has distinct roots it's going
to always factor completely over c but
you know factors completely over k so in
particular i mean the particular
relevance for us is k equal to r
okay so this is so and okay and also you
need this that this doesn't happen this
doesn't happen in lower degree
so basically what the a polarity lambo
says is the following look in the polar
ideal find the smallest degree
in which your a polar ideal contains
a
function with roots and all of the with
all of the roots in the field you want
and roots distinct
that's your rank
so okay so
well so now we can see a difference
between r and c
so notice that by the way okay so let's
do an example what does a polarity lemma
say about the rank of x y to the d minus
one
so the polar ideal yeah that's
the employer ideal is generated by this
so what is going to be the rank if i
look in the polar ideal in what degree
can i see something with all distinct
roots
why didn't you must find my section b
minus one right so i have to go all the
way up to degree d that's the bottom
line right once i hit degree d i have
two polynomials with you know i can
generate two polynomials with no common
roots i can make the roots distinct
but up to degree d i cannot do anything
all right this is clear
so then rank f
i think you have y
oh sorry y to the d sorry yeah that's
right rank f uh x y to the d minus one
is equal to d sorry yeah that's right
because yeah y to the d is in the a
polarity will not y to the s
y to the d minus one you can see it does
not kill it if i apply the differential
operator
also you can see well this is actually
easy to prove
uh that
e over r or over c it follows from this
that rank f
well it follows from a polarity lemma
plus the knowledge of bipolar ideals it
follows that rank f is at most d
and in fact you can see that rank f
equal to d is possible you can also see
that uh you know
over c if you want to achieve rank d
this is basically the only way you can
do it
because you need to have a query because
essentially you need to make sure that
you both of your generators can only
come into play
when you have rank d or when you have
degree d right and in order for this
because the degrees of generators add up
to d plus two one of the generators must
be quadratic the other one must have
degree d and the quadratic generator if
it has distinct roots then the rank is
two
but if it has
double roots
the well which means that it's exactly a
square
then the rank is going to be d
are there questions
okay
so
i guess let me add one more comment i
mean i should have actually said it when
i stated this
when i stated this fact slash exercise
this is also sort of the the other you
can also have an implication the other
way so if you give me g1 and g2 that
have no common zeros over c degree plus
u of g one is equal to plus degree of g2
is equal to d plus 2 then if i look at
the ideal it is going to be the a polar
ideal of some f
so you can also go the other way so
basically in a way there is a sort of a
perfect correspondence between
the aol between
pairs of polynomials like this
and a polarized and forms of degree d
so okay so now let's do another example
just to
illustrate uh the difference
over s over c or over r so imagine that
i have a polar ideal
is
like this
in a way i don't really need to bother
uh computing what this is a polar two i
know that these two things have no
common zeros
i know that their degrees adapt to the
same thing so they are going to be a
polar something of degree d you can
figure out what it is let's say that's
an exercise
but what do i know about the rank of
this thing or the real rank of this
thing
what is the difference between real and
complex rank here
so what is the complexity let's go first
what is the complex ring of this guy
two right because this is a guy with two
real root oh sorry two distinct complex
roots but over reels
what is going to be the rank how far do
i need to go before i can find something
that factors completely over reels
right i have to go all the way up to d
so the real rank so
rank
r is d
and
rank c
okay
so maybe a little bit okay so this a
polar ideal
seems uh awfully useful
uh how does one compute it
so uh
sorry that's the a polar ideal of what
polynomial in this case uh that's an
exercise
and i'm claiming that is a polar to
something
uh because because i know that these
these two guys are a complete
intersection
so it's an exercise to figure out what
this polynomial is
okay
so
yeah so this a polar ideo seems awfully
useful so
how does one compute it so again this
goes back to sylvester even
even so far there's uh the name was made
up by him maybe not the most uh
not the most uh
well nice choice but uh
but i think according to uh bruce
resnick the original name was even
longer so catalexicant is the shortened
is the shortened version of the name so
okay
so
all right so let me take a bivariate
form uh and now i'm going to write it in
with a slightly rescale coefficients
okay so actually let me before uh
before i write anything down what is a
polar ideal doing so what does it mean
so let's ponder the meaning
yes teach you life
oh yeah ditra guys sorry
yes
ah
what is the meaning of d g of f equal to
zero what is it saying well it's saying
that somehow there is a linear relation
between partial derivatives of f of some
order
right so for example if degree of g
degree of g is equal to r
saying that d g of f is equal to zero it
is essentially saying that there is
there is a partial uh there is a linear
relation
between
our partial derivatives
okay so now if i write f in this form i
can form the kth catalytic or i think
m catalectic and matrix cm as follows
so now this is something where i'm going
to get the subscript wrong so let me
look at my notes
and hope that that has the subscript
right
uh so you start with so you take these
coefficients and you arrange it in the
matrix that sort of has henkel format
but it's not necessarily uh
it's not necessarily square
and you go all the way out to cd minus m
cm
c0
so i claim so now this is this is the
this is the so-called amphithelecticunt
and in fact uh well once i once i tell
you how to interpret this matrix you can
generalize it to uh
more variables
so okay so how to interpret this matrix
i claim that
actually every row
every row of this matrix corresponds to
a uh
i guess m partial of f
m partial derivative of f
so for example the top row corresponds
to d d
x to the
m
and then the next one corresponds to d
dx to the m minus one y
i'm hoping that these numbers correspond
very well with the subscripts but i
might be making a mistake here but
anyway every row corresponds to an nth
partial
of f
so basically if i compute the kernel of
this this is going to give me all linear
relations between the partials
or this is going to give me exactly the
kernel so the kernel gives me all linear
relations all linear relations are
exactly what's in the polar ideal
so exercise
kernel of cm
is equal to the degree
uh degree m part of f
so basically i guess bottom line is what
i'm saying how do you compute a polar
ideal it's linear algebra
right so what do you do you take the
coefficients you rescale them you put
them in the matrix you compute the
kernel of the matrix you reinterpret it
as a polynomial
uh
you have your degree and part of the
apollo ideal and i mean the same setup
in a slightly more uh
in a slightly more advanced way it
generalizes to more variables
so you can uh
think about that as well
okay
are there questions
okay so now right where did my ankle
matrix come from so that i gave you this
original example in the very beginning
of the talk and i said that decomposing
f
corresponds to decompose it's equivalent
problem to decompose some henkel matrix
in terms of rank long ankle so when the
degree d is even
when the degree d is even you can take
the middle catalyticant
okay so when d is 2k
you can take ck it's going to be now a
square k plus 1 by k plus 1 matrix
it's going to exactly have the ankle
format c 0 c c d c d minus 1 c d minus 1
all the way down to c 0.
so i'm going to call it hf
the hinkle matrix of f and
another sort of exercise
so
what does this
what does this correspondence do so
basically you know i can equivalently
think between the polynomial or the
henkel matrix i see all of the
coefficients of the polynomial in the
heinkel matrix so you could think of
there is i don't know a linear map or
you know there's just a one-to-one
correspondence between polynomials and
hinkle matrices but then you could ask
what do rank 1 hinkle matrices
correspond to
under this correspondence and the
exercise is rank h
so rank hf
is equal to 1 if and only if f is some
d power of a linear form
so
so that's where the equivalence between
the two problems come from i can think
about the polynomial of even degree or
its corresponding hinkle matrix and then
if i decompose it as a combination of
powers this exactly corresponds to
decomposing this matrix as a linear
combination of rank one hinkles
that's uh
that's all that there is
okay
so
in a way uh this is
i mean this is just really general
background on
wearing problem in two variables
uh so
i will now go into sort of more more
what happens over reals
and maybe
after making one more point
um are there any questions right now
okay so
now what happens uh
what happens to this uh problem over c
and over r
why is there a big difference
well one difference is
the following so okay so f perp
is generated by g1 and g2 this is always
true you know linear algebra works the
same way over reals or over c
right nothing really changes so you can
compute f perp just using linear algebra
and the degree of g1
plus degree of g2
is equal to two oh sorry it's equal to d
plus two
so now basically what happens is once
you start computing these catalytic
matrices with generic entries or in
other words for a generic choice of
polynomial f you expect these guys to
have full rank for as long as they have
for as long as it's possible for as long
as they're well you expect them to have
full rank always but you expect them to
have no kernel for as long as it's
possible
and for as long as it's possible means
as long as there are uh
more
which one is it as long as there are
more rows than columns you expect there
to be no kernel
okay so you expect them to have no
kernel for as long as you can and
essentially what it says is that outside
outside of a risky
closed set
in rxy
also in kxy
always want to write it in real so
outside of the risky closed setting kxy
degree of g1
well there are two cases degree of g1 is
equal to
degree of g2
is equal to k plus 1
where done d is equal to 2k when it's
even and the degree of g1
is equal to
k plus 1 and the degree of g2
is equal to k plus 2 when d is 2 k plus
1.
so it's slightly different there is a
bit of a difference between even and not
degree
but in fact uh yeah so
so you might wonder what is this the
risky uh
close set so the risky close set so when
d is 2k
this the risky closed set is given by
determinant of the ankle matrix is equal
to zero so basically as long as your
henkel matrix is non-singular
you have your a polar ideal i will call
generated and generic degrees so you're
a polar ideal is generated in generic
degrees if your ankle matrix is singular
then it's not generated in generic
degrees but in any case
this sort of occurs inside
either over c or over r it occurs
on a the risky closed set
this is the risky closer than a x y d
oh yeah that's sorry sir yes that's
right
that's right
you can also write down explicitly
what happens you know when the degree is
odd but for this talk i will mostly
focus on the case of even degree which
is
often all over reals is going to be
is going to be
more
uh more interesting more delicate so
yeah so what's going to happen okay so
what happens over c let me just uh
finish saying it so basically
let's let's look at even degree when
your henkel matrix has full rank you
have two generators both of degree k
plus one
they have no common roots
so this means that i can always find
something of degree k plus one that
factors completely over c and this means
that here so basically
so degree is 2k if determinant hf
is not equal to 0 then rank
f is equal to k plus one
it cannot be less than k plus one
because there is nothing in a polar
ideal of degree less than k plus one
and similarly you know if you if you are
outside of was a risky closed set uh
when d is two k plus one then the rank
is going to be again k plus one
because generically your lowest degree
generator is going to have distinct
roots
sometimes it will not but generically it
will have distinct roots
okay now over r the situation is a bit
different
because
basically there is no such thing as a
unique generic rank so here you see that
outside it was a risky closed set the
rank is exactly the same
and it's also pretty easy to figure out
what it is
i mean it's also i mean everything is
known so you can also figure out what
happens for example when cancel matrix
is singular how to determine rank but
over r the situation is different
so over r the situation is quite
quite a bit different
so what happens over r
so let me denote by sr
this is the set
of all
forms
of rank r
okay so
now with definition
rank r is called
typical
if sr
contains
an open set
in the usual the an open subset
in the usual
the risky topology of
r x y d
and over reels
over reels we know that essentially
all of the eligible ranks
are typical so meaning that all ranks
are well
you can see that essentially you cannot
have an open subset if your rank so
yeah well let me first state this here
so all ranks are
such that
r is between
the floor of d plus two over two and d
are typical
uh so you can see by basically it's
going through a polar ideal that if you
pick too small if you pick too small you
have absolutely no chance of getting
hitting an open subset
and we already discussed that the
maximal rank can be at most d
so so the key question is is it true
that everything in between is typical
and the answer is yes this is actually
more general
and we but the initially this was uh
conjecture of kimono taviani who proved
that this was typical and this was
typical
and then uh they conjectured that
everything in between is typical and
that's actually more general phenomenon
any rank between the minimal typical
rank and the top typical rank is always
typical
even if you don't look at bivariate
things even if you just look with
respect to rank to a variety but in any
case for us we know that these are the
typical ranks
and uh so i guess the main point of the
talk
is that
very little is known about these sets
sr so let's just focus on the ones where
we have a ball
okay so we so let's focus on the typical
one so what can we say about this set
ssr so what is the set of all forms of a
given
of a given typical rank so we're in
within this range
okay
so something very nice something very
nice can be said uh for the top typical
rank so the top typical top rank and top
typical rank is d
so
there is a very nice theorem to which i
guess we made a tiny contribution
uh so the theorem is the following
so let me write some attributions maybe
in some reasonably
chronological order
so what does it say so it says rank f
is equal to d
if and only if
f has only real roots
such polynomials sometimes called
hyperbolic or real stable so it says
that
f
has maximum rank
if and only if you have only real roots
i don't understand
i mean let's take f equal to x to the d
oh okay if it's not a power
and f is not really the f is not equal
to a power of linear form
that's the only exception
but even if it has
so
so so in the case
higher multiplicity
yeah so okay let me state something so i
think let me state some what what
happened with this theorem so i think
bruce resnick proved
this direction
uh
and also conjectured that this is
actually the case
now come on in the taviani proved the
whole thing when d was small maybe if
i'm right maybe something like five and
they sort of laid out the plan of how
one would prove it modulo some work
uh if f has distinct roots if f has
distinct roots and then this work was
later done by carouse and ray so this
was a theorem except that perhaps if f
has multiple roots but the multiple
roots are complex there was still no
sort of maybe it still has maximum rank
so essentially our contribution is to
remove the last little bit but most of
the work was already done by the people
listed so but yes so that works even if
f has multiple roots so
you only if f has all real roots do you
have that the rank is maximum if and
only
okay
so
but an interesting thing here is that
even though we have in a sense
sort of a perfect understanding
of what's going on here
um
it's not clear so basically how does the
proof work the proof i mean all of these
proofs they work by induction and in a
way it's very ad hoc it's very ad hoc so
i could ask can i understand this
statement in terms of a polar ideal
right so f probe is generated by some p
and q how do i write out p and q so that
i don't hit and how do i know that i
will not hit the form with all real
roots you know until very high degree so
this understanding is kind of missing i
mean i know how to prove this
but the proof doesn't really tell me so
in understanding this in terms of the a
polar ideal is not very clear
uh yeah because the proof is inductive
the proof is inductive it doesn't really
really tell you what's going on
okay
so notice that i mean so well what else
i just want to mention a few things so
this set is basically
almost closed
so i'm talking so what i mean what is
that sd so the set of all things of rank
d it is almost closed because yeah we
don't have the powers
uh it's almost a closed set
uh its boundary is essentially given by
is the boundary is given by the
discriminant
well its boundaries given by boundary
are polynomials
polynomials with all real roots
with all real roots
i don't understand we're almost closed
means
well
uh you have powers right so i can
approach a power by something that has
all of your roots so it's only missing a
small cartridge boundary yeah i'm i'm
only missing a tiny part of the boundary
in the set
if you don't like the almost closed
that's okay you don't have to like it
i'm not forcing it to you but uh but in
my but from my point of view if i take a
tiny part of the boundary away the set
is almost closed
so polynomials is all real roots and
multiple roots
and if you think about the algebraic
boundary meaning that i just take the
risky closure
then the algebraic boundary only has one
component it's given by the discriminant
so are those missing points exactly the
extreme points of the
extreme no this is not there's no
convexity here
there's no convexity here
okay
so now basically what i want to tell you
is a little bit
about what happens
for the other extreme which is the
minimal typical rank and i'm going to
focus on the case of even degree where
the minimal typical rank is k plus one
sorry just
yes
the dimension of this set
of it's full dimension right i can take
a polynomial with all real roots no
matter how i perturb it it's going to
have real roots as long as they're
distinct
that's why it's typical rank
so it's full dimensional because i can
perturb it and it will stay
of that rank because because of the
characterization
so
if you use the usual
uh
measure of volume that people have been
using
is this the largest or the smallest
who knows
there is absolutely i mean yeah there is
absolutely no i mean okay let me put it
this way
i'm going so this this case is well
understood i'm going to tell you
something
uh i mean a reasonable amount of things
about this case
all right the minimal one and in between
i would say it's completely wide open to
understand what these guys are
so before we start measuring their size
it would be reasonable i mean
i mean i'm just guessing i mean perhaps
you can measure their size without
understanding things about them somehow
but
it's either the largest or the smallest
right why why why i don't see i guess my
idea of justice does not correspond to
uh
well there is i mean other other sort of
extreme sadness cases where you have to
extremely dream about reality that that
often happens on an extremely small set
right well okay i i really have not
thought you know what is the natural
measure and so on but i mean
in a way this does not look small i
don't know
but maybe it is maybe i'm just not
thinking about it in the right way
okay so right so what do i want to say
about the the minimal typical rank so
yeah let's focus on the even degree
so
yeah so d is 2k
so i'm looking at sk plus one
uh this is the guy with this is the set
of all forms with minimal typical rank
so
i don't know proposition
so sk plus one
is an open set
uh it's not connected
it has
let's see uh hopefully
i will get this right
whether it's connected components
uh maybe silly
and where do these connected components
come from so connected components
how i can enumerate them they
correspond to the signature
different signatures
of the henkel matrix
but of course i'm looking projectively
so signature means the signs of the
eigenvalues
so uh
if i'm looking projectively f is the
same as minus f so plus plus plus plus
plus is the same as minus minus minus
minus so up to this equivalence of uh
plus signature and minus signature
they're exactly indexed by the
signatures of the henkel matrix yeah
these are the connected components and i
guess in order to
uh in order to understand this so first
of all i guess exercise or
if
if the determinant hf is equal to zero
in other words if the polar ideal is not
generated in generic degrees
then
rank f
is not equal to k plus 1.
so basically if the ankle matrix is
singular
then i cannot have rank d plus one
why is that well essentially if the
ankle matrix is singular i'm going to
have a generator that has degree less
than k plus 1.
if it has all these things to your roots
then the rank is less than k plus 1.
if it doesn't have all these things to
your roots then i will not be able to
get all this because you see the sum of
the
the sum of the degrees of g one and g
two is two k plus two
so if the degree of g one
is less than k plus one
then the degree of g two
is greater than k plus one
so either g1
has distinct real roots in which case
the rank is less
or if the g1 does not then i have to
wait for a while to hit g2 more than k
plus 1 and that's the only way that i
can get to distinct real roots because
obviously multiples of g1 are not going
to suffice
okay
so
so the bottom line is so the singular
guys are not interesting to me and that
means that you know any time i want to
get from one signature to another
i have to cross
you know the eigenvalue has to hit zero
and that means that the signature well
there should be at least as many
connected components as there are
signatures
and in fact they're just indexed by
so they're not more
and in the way this also you can draw
sort of a mental picture so this is a
bind show so it's a combination of a
bunch of open
sets and i guess the uh the mental
picture is that these open sets sort of
looks like a sausage
um
what do i mean by that well
you know if i start with the signature
plus plus plus plus plus plus plus i can
only you know one i can i cannot reach
just any component right i can only
change one eigenvalue at a time
uh so i can
do plus plus plus plus plus plus plus
plus minus unless i go through specially
singular point right and then the next
time i can only you know i can only
change uh you know to another minus
and so on so that's what i mean it's
kind of in a way laid out like a sausage
you know they're in the row
okay
um
questions
well
is this result possibly true also for
all of the degree uh yeah so there is a
corresponding result for a degree uh i
mean about there is no signature of the
hand committees no but we can also
describe the case about
metal degree uh let me try to remember i
think i think the answer is yes uh but
maybe i'm misremembering something i
think the answer is yes
wow that's really
quite beautiful
so
okay um
i guess okay so i want to say a few more
things but
there is okay there is something that
actually okay
there's something that's beautiful here
that actually i still want to describe
uh so how can you
so there is so there is a correspondence
so there is well
in order to have degree d plus one oh
sorry in order to have rank k plus one
you must be generated in generic degrees
so basically what we're looking at
uh well okay this one i actually want to
i want to keep
so let's go to this board okay
let's go to this point
greg can i ask you a question off the
scan yeah this proposition suppose you
replace every angle matrix by its
inverse
do you know whether that takes well but
the universe over henkel is not hinkle
right
do you know what happens to the
connected components under that
transformation um
i'm not sure i mean because i'm not i'm
not sure which space they lie i mean
what what space i should think of they
certainly don't correspond to forms
anymore right they just correspond to
symmetric matrices
okay
so
yeah so off the top of my head i don't
have an interpretation of what's
happening
all right so yeah so how can you so i
have i have f and af verb now let me
just say it's generated by p and q they
are of the same degree the degree of p
is equal to degree of q
is equal to k plus one
uh how can i read off the signature
let's say i'm just given i'm just given
the pencil so i'm just giving pencil pq
are my given two forms
so the pencil just refers to linear
combinations let's say alpha p plus beta
q how can i read off of course if they
have no common roots it's a polar to
something so i can
i can find the a polar thing i can find
would i can find given p and q i can
find the f i can build the ankle matrix
i can take the signature but
there should be a way for me to see the
signature just by looking at p and q
maybe without computing all the way to
the a polar guy
and then uh
writing the uh and then writing out the
matrix and finding its signature and in
fact the answer is yes so how can i do
it so basically
what i want to describe is signature of
hf
just from p and
q so here's how it works i'm only going
to say it in words uh
and then you can we can write down the
theorem later so let's say that the
degree is four
and so what is this
this is my this is my picture of p1 rp1
is a circle what i wrote down here is
are the roots of p and q
okay so these are the roots of p and q i
sort of well i don't have a good term
for this i call it kind of an
interlacing diagram okay so these are
the roots of p and q how they lie on p1
now what i can do i can make an
equivalence relation any time i have two
roots of the same polynomial i can make
them come together without crossing the
roots of the other guy and i can make
them disappear and make them complex
so under this transformation
this guy is equivalent to this you know
i can make these two guys go i can make
these two guys go away but now i cannot
because they're completely interlaced
right so now there is no more reduction
so in fact i claim that essentially the
signature
isn't one-to-one correspondence to
interlacing diagram signature of hf
isn't one-to-one correspondence to the
interlacing diagram of a pencil and for
example
uh
the fully interlacing diagram
corresponds to exactly hf
being positive definite or in other
words signature plus plus plus plus
and then you can see so as
soon as you're taking you know as soon
as you start taking these guys away if
you have less interlacing you're going
to
introduce negative eigenvalues
okay
so now
uh so that's kind of quite beautiful um
though i cannot say that i mean i know
how to prove it i cannot say that i sort
of fully understand it
uh okay and
so now right so what did we say here so
this guy was almost closed it's actually
also i forgot to mention but this guy is
obviously connected
so here we have uh this guy is open
you know so the minimal typical rank the
set is open it has several connected
components
we can index them by either the
signature of the ankle matrix or the
interlacing diagram we know how to count
them
so now what about the boundary of the
set or in fact algebraic boundary
so let me
state the theorem so what is the
algebraic boundary of this
so algebraic boundary
of sk plus one
has three connected components
uh well one one we already know
one is the determinant of the ankle or
it's also called the middle curl so
equal to zero
one component is just given by the
vanishing of the ankle matrix of the
middle catalytical matrix
so now let me remind so f probe is given
by this pencil pq
so the pencil just alpha b plus beta q
so this pencil contains
a polynomial
with
two double roots
and three
alpha p plus beta q
contains
a polynomial
with
three
with triple root i guess that's with the
trooper
okay do you mean just three components
or do you mean connection oh sorry
connected was not the necessary yeah i
just meant component sorry that was uh
yes because i was talking about
connectivity it's just kind of snuck in
okay so it has three components i
actually don't really know degrees of
these guys although
i have a reasonable guess
so that's an open question in fact it's
one of the exercises
okay
so
time is almost up so what is it that i
want to say uh well
let me maybe state one more uh
one more theorem so you could also ask
you could also ask what about so over
complex numbers
let's focus on this case so d is 2k
right so d is 2k
and rank f
is equal to k plus 1.
so you could ask what is the set of all
the compositions so f curve is key again
it's generated by these two guys p and q
of the same degree
so then in fact when you look at the
pencil alpha p plus beta q
almost any polynomial in this pencil is
going to have distinct roots
and once you have polynomial with
distinct root it naturally indexes a
decomposition you just take the roots of
your polynomial this gives you the
decomposition
i mean you don't know the coefficients
but you know which linear powers to take
then you find out the coefficients
okay so basically over c
over c you can say that this sometimes
called variety of sums of powers is
naturally equal to p1
i mean okay at some point you hit a
double root but you take the risky
closure you have a p1 worth of
decompositions
now what happens over r
well you look inside alpha p plus beta q
so again you look inside rp1 so if you
want a line or i can sort of join it at
infinity into a circle
and now what happens well you might
leave
you might leave so at some point because
you're not not just interested in
distinct roots i won't distinct real
roots at some point you know my pencil
which is just a straight line it might
leave a domain of hyperbolicity so what
i'm going to see is i'm going to see
that well it's not really going to be a
variety of sums of powers
uh i don't have a good name for it it's
a semi-algebraic set of sums of powers
it's going to be a bunch of open
segments
so it's going to be
some collection of open segments
and you know if inside here i have a
polynomial with all real roots it
naturally indexes the composition but at
some point if i take different
coefficient so this is
alpha p plus beta q
you know alpha one plus beta one but at
some point if i take a wrong coefficient
i might leave
the domain with polynomials oh real root
so then you could ask
what is
the largest number of open segments that
i can have
right so how many times can i take a
pencil and make it enter and leave the
domain of hyperbolicity
and
the answer is sort of
maximal possible
so
maximal possible so let me state the
theorem so theorem
says so it's possible that alpha p plus
beta q
uh
v well so
vsop well
how should i put it
the variety of sums of powers of f
were added where f purpose pq
can have
at most
a plus one open segments
and
any number between zero and k plus 1 as
possible
now let me just say why is it k why is
it k plus 1 because so what's happening
here
what is really happening here so i have
a pencil i have a pencil of polynomials
uh now i can think of this pencil as
just a straight line so i have alpha p
plus beta q so projectively this is a
line
in r x y
k plus one
okay so what i have is a line and now
any time i enter so this is the
discriminant locus
anytime i enter the domain of
hyperbolicity i might must cross the
discriminant locus anytime i leave
domain of hyperbolicity i must cross the
discriminant locus so every every every
open segment
corresponds to
taking uh sort of
crossing the discriminant locus twice
now the degree of the discriminant locus
is two times k plus one because i have
forms of degree
k plus 1.
so this means that you know if every
time i pay if for every segment i pay a
price of 2 i can have at most k plus 1
segments the only question is whether
actually i can contrive every time i
cross discriminate locus to essentially
enter leave enter leave enter leave
enter leave and what i'm saying is the
answer is yes
okay
i am out of time actually i'm over time
but i've said all that i wanted to say
so i apologize for extra time and thank
you
are there any questions
okay
this this number this um
signature is also the degree of the real
algebraic mapping
and
i wonder if that can be useful
um
so which normally so you're talking
about the signature of the the number of
different signatures of the henkel
matrix
i believe the
symmetric form defined by the angle
matrix is the form on the middle degree
that's right
algebra that's right and that's also the
topological degree of the math defined
by p and q
oh that's uh that's right in in a way uh
do we actually ever use that uh
yeah i mean in a way we do use it but
maybe indirectly i mean uh yeah
so the other thing i want to ask is
whether you know
anything about the set of f's and more
variables which give complete
intersections
oh the set of what's the set of f such
that the a polar ideal is complete
intersection
um
no i don't know too i mean the only
thing that i can say is that when you
have a complete intersection it's
usually pretty easy to determine what
the wearing rank is
uh
but uh
i mean so that's very helpful but i
don't know yeah i don't know how to
parameterize these things in in any sort
of reasonable way
so about those numbers so zero if you
had these totally interlaced uh-huh the
roots of being totally interlaced you
would get zero
right you would you would always have
real roots that's right your entire line
would stay inside the domain of
hyperbolicity k plus one when they're
sort of totally on interlaced uh
that's certainly one possibility i mean
you because i um
have you looked at
the pictures for each other that's right
so i mean yeah so you can make some
statements so for example you know
they're fully interlacing then for sure
you your your thing is your your line is
going to stay fully within the domain of
hyperbolicity uh i don't remember so
certainly i mean because essentially i
just have a construction i just have a
construction that does it k plus one
times i don't really have a full
understanding and i haven't thought
about this enough of you know what are
the sets of all things where you cross k
plus one times do they all come from
just one connected component of the set
meaning from one segment releasing
diagrams i'm not completely sure in fact
there are a lot there is yeah there are
so i guess one thing that i one
one say one thing i wanted to say is
that there is there is a ton of open
questions here so i mean now this is
just the minimal typical rank and we
understand the maximal typical rank
everything in between is actually much
more complex well
i don't know really how to do things
because i mean essentially there are two
ways that i know how to do things one
for the top rank we have an ad hoc way
uh sorry it was on this board but no
longer we have the ad hoc way of
inductive proof for the minimal guy the
a polar ideal works well
but now you could but now how do i
describe such pencils p and q so that
alpha p plus beta q doesn't contain
something with all real roots but when i
multiply by linears they do this becomes
much more complicated i don't know of a
good way of thinking about it in fact if
i start thinking so this is kind of yeah
it's kind of strange but you know if i
don't think about the result for a
maximum rank in an ad hoc way but i try
to think about in the a polar way it
becomes very unclear how do i define
these two guys p and q
so that you know no combination of them
will have a form with all real roots
until i sort of until i'm forced to have
it
uh so in fact i maybe if i understand
this then this will be the key to
understanding everything in between as
opposed to the inductive way of doing
things but in any case there is there
are actually a lot of
open questions here which i think is a
little bit surprise i mean we're talking
about polynomials in one variable or
henkel matrices uh but anyway
yes you could just
the maximum typical rank for more
variables
uh
no but but there is there is a
i mean there is no general conjecture
there is there is not there is not even
conjecture for the maximal rank well i
don't know in fact i don't know which
one is more difficult the maximal rank
or the maximal typical rank but
something that uh so
me georgio and alexander has been have
been stuck on for a while which is the
sort of the smallest open case is
ternary cortex so you could ask what is
the maximal typical rank defining
exactly the same way of ternary cortex
or just the maximum rank of ternary
cortex both are open
uh yeah so i did put it on the exercises
but i i wrote in the forensics may be
harder
i'm not sure in fact because in a way
in a way i think that we need some new
ideas and with a new idea this might
actually be for ternary cortex and not
in general fraternity this might
actually be a not very hard question
but
but without new ideas
it seems reasonably difficult
so let's stand break again